that
is
empirical proof
that migration is still happening
between this coast and britain we've
watched these people about 40 of them
carrying a very large inflatable boat
putting it in the water crowding onto it
they're now trying to get the engine
working and they've done all that in
full site of the french police a unit of
whom have been stationed on the beach
and have been watching a police
helicopter came overhead and was
watching what happened and they can't
say they hadn't been born because about
half an hour before this
another boat set off same thing same
sort of boat also with about 40 people
on it and it left these shores heading
over towards the british coast and on
that occasion too the french police
watched and did nothing we asked them
why that was the case
now nobody told us officially but i
spoke to one of the officers who said
that there were only eight of them
confronted by what was about 40 people
on the boat and another 40 people around
them the message being quite clearly
that they thought they were outnumbered
the other thing i think to take from
this is that sometimes you can get the
impression that people smuggling between
europe and the british coast is all very
very subterfuge it's done at night it's
done in the small hours and very often
it is but look around us
this is broad daylight these people
carried their boat along a beach in full
view not just of the police but of dog
walkers have passed us by and of us
this
is what people trafficking
looks like sometimes not always that
slick undercover operation
sometimes
as brazen as that